peur que ça change votre vie d'avoir
beaucoup d'argent ça me fasse briller un
petit peu et que je fasse un petit peu
n'importe quoi donc le plus important
c'est de payer mon loyer et que mes
enfants puissent manger tout simplement
il y a une vie incroyable est-ce que
vous êtes comme lui alors non
c'est vrai que l'argent malgré tout tu
perds vite la notion de l'argent quand
tu commences à en gagner tes amitiés
sont différents tes amours sont
différents tu supportes moins de choses
tu peux que tu commenceras de l'argent
tu profites des choses si tu en as plus
c'est pas grave tu reviendras comme tu
étais avant c'est pas vrai ça ça c'est
pas vrai c'est pas vrai que une fois que
tu habites à la business sur tourne pas
les coups effectivement l'argent ça
abîme tout et que au début si tu n'es
pas éduqué pour t'en servir ses preuves
de tous les influenceurs et de tous les
gens qui font de la téléréalité je te
promets que c'est vrai le petit Benoît
qui a gagné la Star Academy
avait des parents à une famille qui
était pas imposable et tout ça et de
l'argent et un jour il m'a dit regarde
ce que j'ai reçu il m'a montré une
feuille d'impôts mais qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire il savait même pas qu'il
fallait payer les impôts quasiment il
n'avait pas l'argent il faut il faut
éduquer l'argent avec les gens avec
l'argent bien sûr qu'effectivement sinon
ça donne des drames